رجال ايرانيون يرتدون الحجاب تضامنا مع
زميلاتهم
مسؤول ياباني يحذر بلادنا ستختفي من
الوجود
توام شهد ابكر ولاده في العالم يدخل
موسوعه
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
في احتجاج ساخر على فرض النظام الايراني
ارتداء الحجاب الاسود على جميع العاملات
في الصيدليات انتشرت على مواقع التواصل
صور لايرانيين صيادله يرتدون الحجاب
كتضامن مع زميلاتهم منظمه الغذاء والدواء
الايرانيه كانت اصدرت تعليمات للصيدليات
تقضي بان على جميع النساء العاملات في
الصيدليات ارتداء حجاب اسود ويجب على مؤسس
الصيدليه الاشراف على تنفيذ هذه التعليمات
وكانت وسائل الاعلام المحليه افادت باغلاق
عدد من الصيدليات والمكاتب الطبيه خلال
الاسابيع الماضيه وذلك بسبب عدم مراعاه
ارتداء الحجاب الاسود
اثار تصريح لوكيل مجلس الشيوخ في مصر بهاء
ابو شقه حول مدخرات وتحويلات المصريين
بالخارج اثار غضبا كبيرا وسخريه واسعه
ايضا على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي وسائل
الاعلام المحليه نقلت عن ابو شقه مطالبته
باستقطاع نسبه من تحويلات وعائدات
المصريين بالخارج لمصلحه الدوله كرد
الجميل لبلدهم التي ربتهم وعلمتهم على حد
وصفه فيما تدخلت وزيره الهجره سها جندي
سريعا وحسمت هذا الجدل قائله ان تحويلات
المصريين في الخارج هي ملك لهم ولا نتدخل
في الحسابات الشخصيه للمصري في الداخل او
في الخارج
اليابان هذه المره حيث حذرت ماساكوموري
مستشاره رئيس الوزراء الياباني من ان
بلادها ستختفي من الوجود ما لم يتم اتخاذ
اجراءات سريعه للحد من تباطؤ معدل
المواليد في البلاد وفي مقابله مع وكاله
بلومبرغ وبعد اعلان الحكومه عن انخفاض
المواليد قالت موري اذا استمرينا على هذا
النحو فان البلاد ستختفي فيما ياتي لتحذير
المسؤوله بعد ايام من اعلان طوكيو في
الثامن والعشرين من فبراير الماضي انخفاضا
عدد المواليد خلال العام 2022 الى مستوى
قياسي اي بنسبه 5.1% عن العام 2021
وفي خبر يتعلق بالمواليد ايضا احتفل
توامان كنديان شهداء ابكر ولاده في العالم
احتفل بعيد ميلادهما الاول ودخولهما
موسوعه جينيس للارقام القياسيه بعدما لم
يكن لديهما اي فرصه للبقاء على قيد الحياه
الفتاه اضيا والصبي ادريال ولد في الرابع
من مارس 2022 حين كانت والدتهما في
الاسبوع الثاني والعشرين من الحمل ليحطما
بذلك رقمين قياسيين الاول لابقر ولاده
لتوام والثاني لادنى وزن يولد به التوامان
اذ بلغ وزن اذيه عند ولادتها 330 غراما في
مكان وزن ادريال 420 غراما وفقا لما ذكره
بيان موسوعه جينيس
وفي خبرنا الاخير توصل فريق بحثي الى ان
احد انواع البكتيريا قد يكون مسؤولا عن
خفض نسبه ماده الكولاجين في الوجه وهو ما
يعتبر سبب رئيسيا بظهور التجاعيد مجله
فوكس الايطاليه اوضحت ان دراسه علميه
جديده كشفت ان ميكروبيوم الجلد وهو مجموعه
الفطريات والبكتيريا والفيروسات الموجوده
على جلدنا كشفت انه يحتوي على بكتيريا
تلعب دورا في ظهور التجاعيد فيما يحاول
العلماء حاليا البحث عن كيفيه او في كيفيه
الحد من اثار تقدم العمر عبر دراسه هذه
البكتيريا بشكل معمق